- [Interviewer] All right, Tiffany.
- Yeah. Hi.
- [Interviewer] Hi.
Where you from originally?
- [Tiffany] I'm from Panama City.
- [Interviewer] You're homeless right now?
- [Tiffany] Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] How
long you been homeless?
- Recently I got out
of County two days ago,
so it's been two days again,
my second run being homeless.
- [Interviewer] You got where?
- On my second run being homeless.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Yeah, I did five months in County.
- [Interviewer] Oh, for what?
- Commercial burglary.
- [Interviewer] Oh, is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And that's
the first time you've been
to prison or jail?
- No, it's the third time
considering being in the County,
like after 18.
And when I was a teenager, I
was always coming in and out.
- [Interviewer] So you've
been in jail three times?
- Four times.
- [Interviewer] And what
for? All the same stuff?
- Yeah, it's all the same case.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- Right now, I'm 21.
- [Interviewer] Twenty-one.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
- My what?
- [Interviewer] Your childhood.
- As a childhood, I always liked to...
I was very different than the other kids
'cause I always just
liked to be (indistinct)
and being always...
Doing something...
I dunno, what you could say
an average kid would be doing.
I always be in the backyard digging holes.
I dunno, I was just, I was very...
I was a outcast.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I mean,
not everyone's a conformist.
- Yeah. Right.
- [Interviewer] For sure.
There's nothing wrong
with being an outcast.
- Right, and that's what
I like about myself.
- [Interviewer] You can
be more unique that way.
- Sometimes people don't
understand the things that I do
and why I do them, but-
- [Interviewer] A lot of
people don't understand.
- Yeah. But there's
actually a reason for it.
- [Interviewer] Do you
consider yourself gay,
or what do you consider yourself?
- [Tiffany] I consider myself transgender.
- [Interviewer] Transgender.
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Okay. Cool.
And where would you like to
see yourself in five years?
- [Tiffany] I'd like to
see myself in five years
in a mansion and with a bunch of cars
in a mansion,
yeah, in the hills.
- [Interviewer] And what
do you do for money now?
- [Tiffany] Oh, right
now I'm prostituting.
- [Interviewer] You are?
- [Tiffany] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So what
kind of guys do you pick up?
- [Tiffany] Any types
of guys. Just depends.
I mean, I pretty much do all types of guys
'cause it's the money that I'm
after at the end of the day.
So it's like, that's
what I need to survive,
so it's, I mean...
- [Interviewer] Tell me a crazy story.
I'm sure you've got a few crazy stories.
- [Tiffany] About prostituting?
Not really.
I haven't really been there yet
where something like
that has happened to me,
where somebody has hit
me or something, but...
- [Interviewer] That's good.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, there's a
lot more for me to experience.
- [Interviewer] Be careful out there.
- [Tiffany] Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] How do your
parents feel about this?
- [Tiffany] My mom, generally she feels
like it's something wrong right now.
They feel on her it's...
I feel like on her it's like...
She feels sad for her
'cause I'm doing this or
this lifestyle I chose,
but this is what I like doing.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
So at what age did it become
clear that this was your path?
- Probably when I was like 18.
- [Interviewer] Eighteen, so
this was just a few years ago.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends?
- No.
- [Interviewer] No friends?
- I mean, I have a couple
people I talk to here and there
around the tents in...
What is it?
- [Interviewer] Skid Row?
- Skid Row.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But I mean, I wouldn't
call them friends.
I have a boyfriend right now.
His name's Jason Underwood.
Recently we stopped...
We recently stopped talking because
I just don't wanna be
doing stuff behind his back
and then be talking to him
'cause I feel like that's
gonna make it even worse,
but I do love the man with all my heart,
and I have him right here inside: Jason.
- [Interviewer] It was tattooed.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So this is
all you're wearing tonight.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Interviewer] And it's gonna be cold.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] What are you gonna do?
- Try to start wa...
What I do is pretty much
I start walking more.
And the more I get to walk,
the more you go to find someone
that's just strolling by
and says, "Oh, hey, what's up?"
- [Interviewer] You get in the car.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And where
will you sleep tonight?
Or will you sleep tonight?
- Um...
- [Interviewer] You don't know yet.
- I don't know yet.
- [Interviewer] So drug-wise,
crystal meth is your drug of choice?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And how
long you been doing that?
- Since I was 15.
- [Interviewer] Fifteen?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And was that
the first time you did drugs?
- Yeah, it was the first
time I started using drugs.
And then it was around 16,
17, 18, 19, 'til today.
I did a year sober in 2017.
Was it? And yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Well, thank you for talking with me.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, no problem.
- [Interviewer] Good luck out there.
It's crazy.
- [Tiffany] Yeah, it is.
- [Interviewer] Try to be safe.
- Right. Thank you.
- [Interviewer] All right.